(upbeat music)
- Hey everybody, Buenos días,
my name is Raymond Simpson.
I am a Museum Assistant here
in Entomology at the Peabody Museum.
I am a self-professed moth nerd
and I am very interested
in the biodiversity
and evolution of Arthropoda,
specifically insects.
Today I am going to show
you some of our spectacular
diversity in butterflies and moths
that live in the neotropics,
which is basically from
the Southern United States
all the way down to
Argentina in the neo world.
Most of the specimens are preserved
as dried pinned material
like you can see here.
Specimens that are collected in the wild,
are pinned and dried and then
labels are adhered to them
and they are put into the collection
for scientists to come
and observe and study.
So one of my main passions
is butterflies and moths.
As you can see the tropical
region of the neo world,
including Central and South America,
has very high insect diversity.
Lots of like literally tens of thousands
of species of butterflies and moths,
which are scientifically
known as Lepidoptera,
occur in this region.
Here's a good assemblage of butterflies
called 88 butterflies.
They're called 88 butterflies
because the underside of them
have this cool 88 pattern
on their hind wing.
So the top is very brightly
colored, kind of blue and pink.
The bottom has this
cool modeled 88 pattern
or just kind of cool zigzag
black markings on them.
So there's several themes in butterfly
and moth diversity in the
tropics besides just diversity
and I'm going to show you
some of those things today.
One of the most well
known types of butterflies
in the tropics that you've
probably seen before
are called morphos.
And morphos are very spectacular looking
and there's numerous species of morpho,
this is one particular species
it's very common in Brazil,
but it's found throughout South America.
And they're very distinctive
and they have this really
beautiful iridescent pattern.
As I angle the box up,
you could see the pattern,
the hue of the blue
changes in intensity.
So each butterfly has wings coated
in very, very, very tiny
scales that coat the wing.
And each of those scales
is like a reflector
and it reflects back the blue.
So if you look at it under the microscope,
it's like a prism where it
reflects different colors
but it's very strongly
blue back to our eyes.
And it really interesting about
these butterflies is like,
you think like, okay, how
are they very adaptive,
being so brightly colored.
But these butterflies
use this as an ability
to basically see each
other as their own species.
So female butterflies of
this species look like this
and males look like this,
that's called sexual dimorphism.
So a lot of these butterflies
will use color pattern
as a way to recognize individuals
of their own particular species.
Also these butterflies
aren't always what they seem,
so the underside of the morpho
butterfly is camouflaged.
So a lot of things in the tropics
will not only use bright
colors to warn predators
that they don't taste good,
they also use camouflage
to protect themselves
when they're at rest.
So these butterflies will
sit kind of like this.
So I'm going to angle in
the camera or the one,
the butterflies folded up,
you can only see this brown
part, but when they open up,
they flash this really beautiful blue.
So they both have the
advantage of camouflage
and a flash of bright
color to potentially starve
their predators of food.
So these were blue morphos,
I have another example of morphos
just to show you the diversity.
These are actually different species
and these morphos are from
different parts of South America,
but it shows the variation that
you can see in the tropics.
And so this is a different color pattern
of the blue morpho but
a different species,
have a different wing shape.
And this is an another
species it's very pearly
and just like the other
species I showed you,
these morphos also have
a really interesting
underside pattern, which offers
them very good camouflage.
So the next topic I'm going to mention,
that's very commonly
encountered in the tropics
is something called mimicry.
And mimicry is a topic
that is kind of complex,
but it's really easy to understand
once you look at it more closely.
So these butterflies here
are called heliconian butterflies
and heliconian butterflies
have caterpillars
that feed on toxic plants.
So when the caterpillars grow up,
when they pupate and
emerge as butterflies,
they will basically inherit
the caterpillar's toxicity
from eating those plants.
So when you have these
adults flying around,
these adults are gonna need to
be toxic to birds and mammals
and any other predators
that might want to eat them.
So in some cases you actually have moths
and other insects that will actually mimic
the pattern of these
heliconian butterflies.
So predators basically are
tricked into thinking that
they are distasteful
when they really aren't.
So you could as a something
that doesn't taste
particularly bad, you could actually,
by using the coloration of
a heliconian trick predators
into not eating you.
So this is actually a really common thing
amongst tropical butterflies.
And you actually have
these groups of species.
It's a really good example
of evolution in action,
because you have even within a species,
all these different colors.
So all of these are all the same species
of heliconian butterfly.
And these heliconian butterflies
are basically adapted
to different areas of South America,
have different colored model species.
So these model species
are different colors,
so the mimics become
the same color as well.
And so over time you have
all these different associated
butterflies and moths
that kinda looked like each other
and also change as you go
from say, Colombia to Brazil.
So another example of
mimicry we see here is,
these are all types of moths.
So this is an assortment of
moths collected in the tropics.
You can see moths are much more diverse
in pattern, shape and
color than butterflies are.
And they're also more species rich.
There's many tens of thousands more moths
than there are butterflies,
pretty much anywhere you go
including the United States.
So this species in particular
is very interesting
in that a lot of people
might think this is a wasp.
This is actually a moth.
And this is a type of Batesian mimicry,
which is basically a
harmless species of moth,
mimics a species that's harmful a wasp.
So through evolution, you have the,
basically the adaptation of the moth
to evolve clear wings to look like a bee.
You can see here, it has clear wings,
you can see my hands through it
and has the really cool like yellow
and black striped pattern
characteristic of wasps.
So any predator that sees us in the wild
is going to think twice about eating it
because it's very much like a wasp.
A lot, even a lot of human
collectors are fooled by these
as far as like what species is what.
And you sometimes you have
to look really closely
to be able to determine them.
My final box of moths here is,
these are examples of Urania,
which are actually day flying moths.
So you might think, what's the difference
between a butterfly and a moth?
A butterfly tends to fly during
the day and a moth at night.
Not necessarily, that's
probably true of 90% of them,
but these are good examples of moths
that fly during the day
and they actually mimic
swallowtail butterflies, which
have these nice projections
called tails, they call
them tails in a butterfly.
But these moths do a pretty done good job
of mimicking a butterfly.
And the only way you can really tell
is by looking at their antenna.
So on the antenna of this moth,
doesn't have a club tip a ball
on the tip of the antenna.
Usually butterflies,
swallowtail butterflies
have that enlarged antenna tip,
so they tend to be easy to tell
if you look at the antenna.
So between lots of these
butterflies and moths,
you have a lot of
diversity in size as well.
So this is a good example of a,
this is called a white witch
and this is a black which.
You can see based on the scale,
this is the largest moth
in wing span in the world,
this white witch moth.
And the interesting thing about this
is that the caterpillar
was only recently like,
I think people had have photographed it,
but the caterpillar still
remains undescribed to this day.
And if you've seen
caterpillars of large moths,
they could be pretty big.
So it remains to be seen that
this caterpillar of this butterfly,
which this isn't it, so unknown,
if you could find the
caterpillar of this butterfly,
which is going to be or of this moth,
which is gonna be quite big,
you can contribute to science.
So even within our biggest
butterflies and moths species,
there's a lot of work that
could be done by even people,
even citizen scientists going out
and studying your local area.
You could make contributions to science,
even on stuff like this.
(upbeat music)